de commencer notre audition en vous
remerciant de bien avoir voulu répondre
à notre invitation pour poursuivre les
travaux de commission d'enquête à
travers cette table ronde que nous avons
souhaité organisé sur l'ingénierie
locale en matière de rénovation
énergétique donc nous recevons
aujourd'hui les représentants de deux
organismes le Centre d'études et
d'expertise sur les risques
l'environnement la mobilité et
l'aménagement plus communément connu
sous le nom de cerema qui est représenté
par Monsieur Pascal Bertaud son
directeur général et par Madame
Annabelle ferry directrice territoire et
ville monsieur vous êtes ingénieur
général des ponts des eaux et des forêts
et vous avez auparavant exercé les
fonctions de directeur général de
l'Institut national de l'information
géographique et forestière l'igéenne est
de président de l'Office national de
l'eau et des milieux aquatiques l'ONEMA
le cerema est un établissement public
assez récent lui aussi puisque ce centre
de ressources de ressources d'expertise
en matière d'aménagement d'urbanisme de
transition écologique et des cohésions
des territoires a été créé en 2014 à la
suite du Grenelle de l'environnement
afin de regrouper 11 composantes notre
réseau scientifique et technique nous
accueillons également la Fédération des
agences locales de maîtrise de l'énergie
et du climat ou flamme enfin qui
représenté par Madame Maryse Combre la
présidente et Monsieur Franck sentier
donc délégué général madame Combes vous
êtes administratrice de l'agence de
l'énergie et du climat de la métropole
bordelaise et de la Gironde vous êtes
par ailleurs conseillère régional de
nouvelles Aquitaine délégué à
l'efficacité énergétique et aux énergies
renouvelables
à sur votre président mandat d'accord
mais vous êtes toujours au bien
et vous avez une délégation aujourd'hui
non d'accord monsieur sentier vous étiez
auparavant notamment le coordinateur de
la fédération et le directeur de
l'agence de l'énergie et du climat du
Centre et Sud Yvelines votre fédération
fait suite à une Assemblée constituante
des agences locales de maîtrise de
l'énergie et du climat ou Alec qui se
sont réunis en 2004 afin de créer flamme
je rappelle que les alecques font suite
à une initiative de la Commission
européenne de 1994 école elles sont des
structures à but non lucratifs dont le
rôle est d'accompagner les collectivités
territoriales dans la transition
énergétique de leur territoire
mesdames messieurs dans vos diverses
fonctions que je viens de rappeler vous
intervenez à plusieurs titres sur le
sujet qui nous réunit aujourd'hui à
savoir l'ingénierie locale des projets
de rénovation énergétique et nous
aimerions connaître vos analyses sur les
dispositifs de politique publique qui
sont mises en place quel regard
portez-vous sur les politiques de
rénovation énergétique qui sont mises en
oeuvre quel est votre position sur les
obligations mises en place notamment à
l'issue de la loi climat et résilience
et plus particulièrement concernant
l'interdiction de la mise en location
des passoires énergétiques quel est
votre position sur les dispositifs
d'incitation du type Mappy brénov mais
aussi les C2E ou encore les politiques
d'accompagnement avec France rénov et
puis tout récemment ce qui va se mettre
en place avec mon accompagnateur rénov
au Sénat nous sommes également et
naturellement convaincus que les
dynamiques locales sont particulièrement
importantes pour entraîner des
rénovations réussies comment articuler
l'action de l'État et celle des
collectivités territoriales quel rôle
doivent jouer dans l'avenir les
collectivités territoriales quelle
ingénierie mettre en place au niveau
local pour conduire plus efficacement
des projets locaux de rénovation
énergétique que prévoir en particulier
pour les logements sociaux mais aussi
pour les copropriétés
quelle adaptation des guichets et
accompagnateurs locaux et nécessaire
selon vous alors que Lana a récemment
fait parvenir des consignes aux
collectivités pour obtenir le label mon
accompagnateur Renov avant de vous
laisser la parole pour répondre à ses
premières questions il me revient de
vous indiquer que cette audition est
diffusée en direct et en différé sur le
site internet du Sénat et qu'elle fera
l'objet d'un compte rendu il me revient
également de vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14
434-15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller
de trois ans à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et
de 45000 euros à 100000 euros d'amende
je vous invite donc à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
a levé la main droite et à dire je le
jure on commence peut-être par vous
madame Combre
voilà je vous en remercie je vous laisse
donc la parole je sais pas comment vous
souhaitez peut-être commencer dans
l'ordre peut-être la prison de la flambe
et puis après le directeur général du
cerema et puis et après notre rapporteur
vous posera un syndrome de questions
ainsi que nos collègues qui sont membres
de la commission d'enquête et qui sont
présents avec nous à cette audition la
parole vous est accordée
de quelques mots pour vous situer flamme
précisément
un programme européen en 1984 donc il y
a eu l'émergence de 450 Alec à l'échelle
européenne et il y en a juste une
quarantaine en France
donc ce sont des
Alecs apportent une ingénierie experte
aux collectivités territoriales
voilà forte de leurs 25 ans d'expérience
des agences françaises sont fédérés au
sein du réseau flamme aujourd'hui flamme
c'est une quarantaine d'années
près de plus de 600 salariés oui il faut
que je parle
plus de 600 salariés pardon ce qui
couvre un territoire de 23 millions
d'habitants donc un tiers de la
population française les agents sont
portés par près de 300 intercommunalités
et conseils 1100 communes
donc elles sont inscrites dans le code
de l'énergie à l'article
l211-5-1 pour stipuler qu'elles
accompagnent donc les collectivités
locales dans leur politique énergique
climat donc les Alex sont vraiment un
outil privilégié pour pour les élus
comme vous l'avez rappelé très justement
elles sont neutres et indépendantes
elles favorise l'émergence donc de
projets et de mettant tous les acteurs
autour de la table c'est ça qui est
aussi permet à enfin qui permet aux
Alecs ce format là c'est de pouvoir
mettre les acteurs autour de la table
pour décider des projets portés par
leurs collectivité
leur mission d'intérêt général à but non
lucratif j'insiste souvent là dessus
parce que une fois qu'elles sont portées
par les collectivités les Alecs ne
demandent aucune rétribution de quoi que
ce soit par rapport au service apporté
et elle contribue donc à déployer les
actions d'information de sensibilisation
et de conseils d'assistance technique
elles assurent également l'A
accompagnement de la performance
énergétique de tout bâtiment tout
bâtiment visant bien évidemment à
réduire les consommations limiter les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre lutter
contre la précarité énergétique
favoriser aussi l'émergence d'outils de
production d'énergie renouvelable et
elle répond ainsi donc aux objectifs de
la SNBC et de la neutralité carbone
horizon 2050 donc elles ont en effet une
spécificité ces annexes c'est qu'elles
ont un périmètre d'intervention qui
touche tous les publics c'est à dire que
ça va du particulier vers la
collectivité en passant par les
entreprises donc c'est là où elles
peuvent intervenir sous tout format de
bâtiments les Alecs apportant que cette
ingénierie qui est généralement
mutualisé sur les territoires elles
agissent souvent à l'échelle d'une
métropole d'un groupe d'intercommunalité
voire d'un pays ou d'un département
elle s'adapte vraiment aux besoins du
territoire et sont très malléables très
agiles et une capacité d'adaptation en
fonction des réels besoins des
territoires elles sont impliquées sur le
sujet de la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments bien évidemment puisqu'elles
sont toutes sauf une je crois porteuse
de guichet France rénov
et la rénovation thermique des bâtiments
est donc vraiment un élément clé de la
transition énergétique
puisqu'il faut agir sur tous les fronts
et j'aime souvent à rappeler que le PNUD
donc le Programme des Nations Unies nous
rappelle à son tour que 50 à 80 % des
leviers d'action pour lutter contre le
changement climatique se trouve aux
échelles locales c'est l'échelle locale
qui est vraiment dans l'opérationnalité
pour mettre en oeuvre la transition
énergétique c'est pourquoi ce modèle le
modèle Alec est particulièrement
pertinent pour accélérer ces transitions
au cœur des territoires donc voilà j'ai
voulu brosser un petit peu le périmètre
d'action des Alecs et dans quelles
conditions elles apportent leur service
ce sont des
ingénieurs qui sont vraiment créés par
des élus pour des élus voilà et au
bénéfice de l'ensemble de leurs
collectivité
si vous avez à ce stade quelque chose de
rajouter par rapport à madame la
Présidente après je pense que on viendra
aussi sur toute la question de la
pérennité de vos structures les
difficultés de financement enfin je
pense que le rapporteur aussi des
questions là-dessus
à ce stade ce que vous voulez qu'on
commence à répondre aux questions que
vous avez posées
si vous souhaitez si vous après on y
reviendra forcément hein mais vous
pouvez encore un petit peu le propos
introductif on peut un petit peu élargir
alors l'intérêt si vous voulez c'est que
l'on peut vous faire un retour vraiment
concret de terrain et comme on touche
toutes les formats de bâtiments sur la
rénovation thermique je vais essayer de
vous présenter les choses en fait notre
retour par rapport à la rénovation des
logements pour commencer donc
sur le terrain on souffre énormément de
manque de lisibilité
il y a eu trop de changements de marque
si on puis dire en disant il y en a eu
trois différentes donc Espace Info
Énergie le réseau fer France rénov et
manque de lis aussi sur l'organisation
et le financement y compris le
financement des missions il a eu des
finances ma thème région puis le
programme sars et ta région où est un
département lorsque la région
n'a pas souhaité prendre en compte ce
programme
voilà tous ces changements associés à
l'émergence d'acteurs aussi on a assisté
à une émergence d'acteurs très
opportunistes qui
notamment sur la rénovation des des
combles à 1 euro en ce moment on voit
l'émergence de mais continuellement sur
réseaux sociaux ou par des marches
téléphoniques même si le premier mot
qu'il dit c'est ce n'est pas une
démarche commerciale mais si donc c'est
là le dernier la dernière chose c'est le
PV vous êtes totalement payé par l'État
donc tout ça en fait cette multiplicité
et cette succession de changement on
fait que ça a apporté une méfiance au
niveau des citoyens donc
voilà ils sont pas prêts à forcément
rentrer dans un accompagnement donc je
pense que cet accompagnement a besoin
d'être institutionnalisé reconnu pour
apporter de la fiabilité surtout recréer
aussi de la confiance comme ça existait
un petit peu sans vouloir faire de la
nostalgie mais les Espaces Info Énergie
d'autres fois étaient bien identifiés
quel que soit la structure porteuse et
du coup voilà tout le monde savait que
s'ils allaient là ils allaient recevoir
des conseils et des prérogatives qui
étaient pertinentes qui étaient vraiment
qui tenait à route quoi donc l'arrivée
du nouvel acteur ma prime rénove
s'inscrit voilà c'est un petit peu
particulier aujourd'hui parce que nous
étions ce matin là au premier réunion de
lancement de la concertation de du pacte
territorial entre l'État et les
collectivités sur justement le service
de la pub de public de la rénovation de
l'habitat donc en fait l'état s'empare
vraiment d'une co-construction des
futurs politiques publiques et nous
étions là ce matin donc on a eu quelques
nouvelles sur mon accompagnateur inox
qui finalement devrait
œuvrer officiellement qu'au 1er janvier
voilà ça a été un petit peu reculé dans
le temps mais voilà et donc on a
justement on a eu plein de
questionsnements sur sur cet
accompagnateur Renov notamment
l'articulation entre le service public
qui est quand même toujours et cet
accompagnateur est neuf qui sera portée
par du du privé donc voilà il y a
beaucoup de questions de moi autour de
ça ensuite il y a aussi un manque de
visibilité sur la suite de postsar mais
là on a appris donc quelques jours que
on le dispositif SAR était reporté d'une
année pour nous permettre cette
co-construction justement avec les
différents services de l'État mais
c'était il faut le savoir et je préfère
le souligner que c'était une énorme
source d'inquiétude pour les
collectivités porteuses elles ne savait
plus si oui ou non elles allaient
inscrire ce dispositif dans leur budget
et également une sorte une source de
très forte anxiété de la part des
différents directrices et directeurs
d'agence qu'ils soient en train de
licencier leur personnel ça a été très
très compliqué et très douloureux donc
je pense qu'il faut le il faut le dire
parce que quelque part ce voilà ce
manque d'anticipation créé des troubles
à tous les niveaux et du coup on n'a pas
rangé non plus les liens que l'on
pouvait pouvoir tisser avec avec les
avec nos concitoyens
des financements aussi de travaux qui ne
favorisent pas la rénovation globale
performante ça c'est quelque chose que
l'on pense qui est vraiment essentiel
parce que c'est cette ce type de
rénovation globale et performante qui
permettra la réduction des consommations
d'énergie et là et est limitée aussi les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
et on pense aussi qu'il faut intégrer la
partie adaptation dans qui est très
important c'est là pour le coup ça nous
permettrait d'anticiper pour une fois si
je puis dire donc intégrer la partie
adaptation dans la question aussi de la
rénovation
voilà les financements qui ont porté
essentiellement sur les équipements
on trouve que c'est pas forcément la
bonne solution et bien évidemment parce
que une pacte dans un logement non isolé
en fait c'est de l'argent public
gaspillé et inefficace en termes de
d'isolation donc et donc des missions de
gaz à effet de serre
de temps en temps on peut on a parlé
aussi de la
qu'est-ce qui est plus pertinent est-ce
que de continuer à financer le geste
unique ou pas
donc de ce qu'on nous a dit ce matin ça
s'inscrivait dans le bon sens
c'est-à-dire qu'il fallait que ce geste
soit inscrit dans un parcours parce
qu'aujourd'hui le premier geste qui
concerne très très souvent le
financement d'équipements n'est pas
suivi de n'est pas suivi de fait sur le
les travaux d'isolation et en sachant
qu'en plus pour certaines maisons
certains logements si jamais on met de
l'équipe en place sans isolation le jour
éventuellement où on rentre dans un
programme d'isolation l'équipement
devient surdimensionné
et puis du coup tant qu'il est pas isolé
il est en surconsommation si je puis
dire en tout cas au niveau de
l'électricité si ce sont des packs
là ce que nous avons pointé aussi c'est
les aides financières multiples entre ma
prime rénov ma prime rénov sérénité les
C2E les prêts à taux zéro les
préavancent rénovation tout ça c'est
très très compliqué pour pour le citoyen
c'est compliqué de solliciter ces aides
et c'est compliqué aussi de les obtenir
et de plus le reste à charge reste
encore trop important notamment pour les
ménages en grande précarité et fragile
sur le patrimoine public donc là sur
tout ce qui est rénovation de bâtiments
publics là on souhaite qu'il y ait une
politique vraiment très claire qui soit
posée là c'est exactement comme pour le
logement une multiplicité de d'aide dont
certaines à travers le desils DETR ou
France relance ou le fond vert ou acté
en fait on a l'impression qu'il y a une
diffusion une un saupoudrage un petit
peu d'argent public et on se demande si
le fait de concentrer les efforts ne
serait pas plus pertinent en tout cas
sur le financement et ça favoriserait
peut-être aussi pour les collectivités
d'engager une véritable planification
des travaux
après ce qui fait énormément défaut dans
les territoires parce que j'ai circulé
là j'ai fait le tour de France de toutes
les agences et je circule beaucoup dans
les territoires donc c'est vraiment une
remontée de terrain c'est un manque
cruel à certains endroits d'ingénierie
territoriale c'est à dire qu'on voit
qu'il y a une
la population d'élus qui est vraiment
prête maintenant à s'inscrire dans des
transitions écologiques énergétiques on
voit la limite qu'il pourrait se
débrouiller plus ou moins on va dire
malgré la multiplicité des aides à
capter des financements mais pour autant
ils ne savent pas par où commencer pas
comment s'organiser etc donc cette
ingénierie
territoriale experte elle est elle fait
cruellement défaut
voilà cette ingénierie elle permet aussi
aux collectivités du coup de s'inscrire
dans une vision plus globale de son
territoire elle va pouvoir justement
avoir et de son territoire et de son
patrimoine elle va pouvoir ça va lui
permettre aussi cet ingénierie
lorsqu'elle est présente de prioriser de
planifier et parce que comme tout le
monde le sait tout ce qui est du champ
de la rénovation c'est sur du temps long
ça s'inscrit sur du temps long mais ça
permet d'amorcer cette transition qui a
aujourd'hui elle est toujours très
incertaine parce que par manque de
d'ingénierie
donc nous ce que nous nous efforçons de
faire c'est souvent de mettre en place
dès lors que c'est des demandes des élus
et que ça correspond à un besoin réel
besoin mettre en place une ingénieur
immédialisée surtout sur le tissu rural
c'est très important c'est pas parce que
c'est le territoire rural qui la moins
besoin de d'ingénierie que d'autres ils
en ont absolument besoin c'est pour ça
que l'intérêt de une ingénierie
mutualisée d'une solution enfin c'est ce
que nous pensons en tout cas et
pourraient apporter justement les
financements entre autres des CEP les
conseillers en énergie partagée qui sont
là vraiment au service des bâtiments
publics de ses collectivités porteuses
pour la rénovation du tertiaire privé
alors le décrétaire pour les bâtiments
de plus de 1000 mètres carrés tel qu'il
est sorti et globalement positif
mais là c'est pareil il manque un petit
peu un service public dédié au petit
tertiaire non soumis au décret
il y a eu une petite époque je crois de
service dans le programme SAR à travers
ce qu'on appelle les B1 B2 mais enfin
c'est pas si clarifié que ça et il faut
que ce soit pérennisé parce que là il y
a aussi des besoins
en fait ce que nous pensons c'est que
d'une manière globale l'État doit mettre
en place des politiques publiques de
rénovation énergétique à travers les
dispositifs surtout stables voilà on
manque de stabilité au regard de ce que
je vous ai évoqué qui soit clair aussi
et simple besoin de beaucoup de
simplification autant au niveau des des
particuliers que des collectivités
et aussi porté par des structures de
qualité notre indépendantes on fait en
Martel beaucoup ce terminologies là
parce que c'est ce qui va recréer qui va
permettre de recréer de la confiance
auprès des concitoyens donc cette
neutralité cette dépendance c'est
vraiment indissociable de l'ingénierie
que l'on pourrait apporter dans les
territoires et puis surtout le besoin
d'un financement fiable et pérenne
lorsqu'on parle d'ingénierie au service
d'intérêt généraux il faut qu'on ait une
visibilité là on est tout le temps en
train de fonctionner à travers des
dispositifs des appels à projets et tout
ça c'est très très compliqué et ça
permet pas
disons que le cette ce temps court des
financements apportés et un petit peu en
contradiction avec la mission longue que
l'on a à mettre en place cette
rénovation thermique sur les territoires
voilà je vais
déjà faire
la parole au cerema monsieur le
directeur général et puis madame bien
sûr merci madame le Président peut-être
quelques mots effectivement d'abord sur
le cerema alors effectivement vous
l'avez noté le céréma est récent il va
bientôt avoir 10 ans et en même temps le
céréma c'est finalement l'héritier de de
toute l'ingénierie publique de toute
l'expertise publique on avait
il y a quelques années bâti un texte en
voyant que finalement la construction
des premières voiries en France étaient
centré autour de Lyon les voies romaines
est-ce qu'il expliquait sans doute que
notre siège soit à Lyon voilà donc
effectivement on est aujourd'hui
2000 2500 personnes en gros 2000
ingénieurs et techniciens présents dans
23 villes donc vraiment sur une maille
qui est en gros et celle des anciennes
régions et avec une mission qui est ce
qu'on a appelé l'expertise de deuxième
niveau c'est à dire évidemment en étant
présent à ce niveau régional on peut
être beaucoup travaillé sur
l'élaboration de méthodologie on peut
beaucoup travailler sur l'accompagnement
de collectivités et en même temps on ne
peut pas être celui qui fait le premier
geste que vous évoquiez je m'empêche de
dire je l'ai déjà dit dans d'autres
auditions au Sénat
en réalité on avait un système qui
marchait assez bien ça s'appelait
l'ingénierie public on l'a supprimé et
je pense qu'il est peut-être temps de se
poser la question de savoir si on n'a
pas intérêt à recréer quelque chose de
façon un peu formelle parce que bien sûr
les agences départementales par exemple
apporte pas mal de choses il y a
beaucoup de choses qui existent mais en
vrai on voit que ce besoin nous on est
confronté exactement au même au même
sujet ce besoin vraiment de d'ingénierie
de proximité et particulièrement
évidemment dans les départements ruraux
on le ressent assez fortement et je dois
dire que ce qui est assez frappant
c'est que pour autant il existe beaucoup
de choses y compris des chargés de
mission sur divers politiques financés
par l'État etc mais finalement le besoin
de base qui est finalement quelqu'un qui
réalise le projet
vraiment sur de la maîtrise œuvre
effectivement celui-là aujourd'hui il
manque et c'est bien ce qui manque aux
collectivités
nous alors le CM1 nous avons
effectivement été amené
du fait de réduction assez forte
d'effectif on était 4000 dans les années
2000 on est 2400 on a recentré
effectivement l'activité en gardant
finalement si j'ose dire que que les
sujets qui étaient vraiment majeurs et
et sur en termes de politique publique
et sur lesquels on prétend avoir une
expertise nationale reconnue etc en ce
qui concerne le secteur du bâtiment
justement ça nous a amené à recentrer
notre activité uniquement sur le sujet
de l'efficacité énergie des bâtiments
avec
globalement des sujets de Hard si j'ose
dire sur les fonctionnements des
ventilations la perméabilité des
ouvrants avec à la fois des activités en
matière de recherche et des activités en
matière de développement méthodologie et
puis et notamment beaucoup sur le
terrain une activité
visant effectivement à changer les
comportements et à faire en sorte que le
premier geste avant de commencer à faire
des travaux c'est probablement d'avoir
moins de lumière etc etc on a élaboré
ces programmes cubes avec effectivement
nos partenaires d'abord sur les d'abord
sur les
les activités les bâtiments de bureau
puis
étendu effectivement au scolaire lycée
collège mais maintenant descendu
effectivement au niveau des écoles avec
en gros des démarches pour les écoles en
plus qui marchent bien c'est derrière il
y a un projet pédagogique il y a
toujours des professeurs qui utilisent
ça et on arrive effectivement à des
économies d'énergie qui sont de 10 à
30%. donc c'est quand même assez fort un
effet kiss cool si j'ose dire c'est que
les enfants quand ils rentrent à la
maison
il secoue les parents et donc on est en
train de mesurer ça avec avec notre
partenaire XPM et en gros on voit que ça
change également dans les logements et
l'intérêt effectivement très fort de
cette démarche c'est que finalement en
commençant par j'allais dire ce qui est
facile et qui coûte pas cher parce que
en pratique on met quelques capteurs
quelques trucs mais c'est c'est plutôt
du soft ça coûte pas très cher
ça permet derrière aussi d'être sûr que
au moment où on vient faire des
investissements lourds derrière le sujet
est bien appréhendé si vous ré isolez
complètement par l'extérieur le bâtiment
mais que vous continuez à vivre les
fenêtres ouvertes en fait ça aura servi
à rien donc voilà c'est vraiment une
démarche assez forte alors on l'applique
plutôt alors donc dans le secteur
d'activité l'activité de bureau les
écoles on démarre seulement dans les
logements donc en pratique nous on a peu
d'activités sur le sujet logement mais
très clairement cette démarche elle
monte vraiment son efficacité en disant
je commence par changer les
comportements et après je fais les
investissements lourds
en matière d'investissement on a un
deuxième programme qui qui monte en
puissance assez fortement qui est le
programme sereine sur la mesure des
performances énergétiques des bâtiments
et qui pour nous est un sujet
assez majeur parce que je vois c'est
qu'on aujourd'hui on fait beaucoup de
travaux on dépense beaucoup d'argent on
mesure pas forcément le gain à la sortie
et ça c'est quand même un vrai sujet
entre les promesses si j'ose dire entre
guillemets et la réalité donc on
travaille pas mal sur sur ces méthodes
d'évaluation avec l'idée effectivement
de pouvoir proposer derrière au
gouvernement un programme
d'accompagnement si j'ose dire du des
programmes de travaux pour
systématiquement pouvoir mettre en place
effectivement ce type de de mesure à
posteriori après pour venir sur les
justement les programmes qui ont été
lancés
d'abord et je tiens à le dire
on a quand même une prise de conscience
très très forte au niveau des autorités
publiques à la fois au niveau local
on a exactement les mêmes retours que
que Madame les élus ils veulent faire ce
qui est je trouve intéressant parce que
très objectif effectivement il y a 5 ou
10 ans c'était pas vraiment le cas quand
même donc on a vraiment aujourd'hui une
vraie volonté de faire il y a une vraie
volonté de l'État d'accompagner avec des
programmes qui sont quand même avec des
montants si des montants financiers qui
sont particulièrement importants après
je crois que effectivement il y a
beaucoup de démarches simultanées avec
une visibilité assez faible et je
rejoins tout à fait ce que disait madame
chrome sur le fait que les élus savent
pas trop comment faire un moment il y a
trop d'offres quoi c'est assez c'est
assez spectaculaire
et que effectivement on n'est pas
aujourd'hui complètement en phase entre
le rythme des rénovations et le rythme
de ce qu'il faudrait faire par rapport
aux enjeux de changement climatique sur
les dispositifs ma prime rénov et
surtout sur mon accompagnateur rénov
nous on a le sentiment que c'est
effectivement un petit peu la clé du
système c'est-à-dire de mettre
effectivement des gens qui soient
capables d'accompagner les propriétaires
sur les travaux à effectuer de les
amener effectivement là je rejoins tout
à fait ce qui a pu être dit sur l'enjeu
de mener des programmes un petit peu
globaux et pas simplement du coup par
coup mais ça je crois qu'aujourd'hui
c'est un peu
repris finalement dans toutes les
politiques publiques
mais c'est vrai que je pense qu'on ne
s'en sortira que si on met sur le
terrain auprès à la fois des populations
et des maîtres d'ouvrages des gens qui
sont capables de les accompagner il y a
un dernier un dernier échelon que je
souhaiterais remarqué qui est qui est
l'échelon des entreprises sur lequel
aujourd'hui
l'offre en matière d'entreprise sur ces
questions pourrait être assez largement
améliorées dans la mesure où on est
souvent dans le monde de l'artisanat et
qui est un sujet de formation des
artisans qui est absolument énorme et
sur lequel on aurait certainement
intérêt à monter en monter en puissance
là aussi c'est je crois que les les
artisans ils sont plutôt sensibilisés
sur le sujet simplement ils savent pas
toujours comment faire ou ils appliquent
des méthodes qu'on avait il y a 10 ans
où il y a 15 ans alors évidemment tout
ça évolue à la vitesse grand V donc la
question de la formation des
professionnels nous semble effectivement
essentiel voilà je dirais de façon un
peu globale
le point positif c'est que les moyens
sont là il y a probablement derrière un
petit peu
canaliser et surtout à aider les gens
sur le terrain à bâtir les projets
adamasque à ce stade vous pouvez
rajouter quelque chose non dans ma
précédente on voulait réagir par rapport
à oui non non je suis tout à fait
d'accord et ce qu'a dit skyvoque et
Monsieur Bertho je voulais juste parler
de de ce que l'on a
tout à l'heure on vous avait parlé de la
des problèmes de la
[Musique]
concernant la
les interdictions de
thermique
non c'est pas les pasteurs thermiques
c'est
que j'ai marqué ça
pas les interdictions de
j'ai parlé d'interdiction de mise en
location des passeurs énergétiques oui
si si c'est ça donc sur les
interdictions de de de location sur les
passoires énergétiques alors ça serait
une bonne chose si ça enclenché les
rénovations le seul souci c'est qu'on
constate des fois que c'est mis sur les
marchés et que ça c'est une
problématique et qu'en fait il faudrait
là aussi peut-être anticiper et avoir un
accompagnement plus fort vis-à-vis des
bailleurs et
toute forme de bailleurs sur tous les
bailleurs
de toute propriété que ce soit
individuelle ou copro parce que à ce
moment-là mais il faut leur faire valoir
l'intérêt aussi d'une rénovation et
c'est là où justement on peut se faire
intervenir l'aspect de tiers financement
qui pourrait aider des bailleurs à
rentrer dans la rénovation énergétique
dès lors que on les aide à la
financement de cette rénovation pour
éviter justement de retrouver ces
passoires thermiques du coup sur le
marché ça c'est quelque chose qu'on a
enfin c'est un point de vigilance qu'il
faut avoir je pense très important très
bien monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
pour vos
premières premières explications
d'abord déjà de dire qu'on rejoint tout
à fait ce que vous avez ce que vous avez
pu dire sur la question de l'ingénierie
et du besoin d'ingénierie notamment
auprès des collectivités on a eu tout à
l'heure une table ronde justement avec
le représentant des collectivités c'est
évidemment ce qui est ce qui est
également ressorti quoi c'est à dire que
si on veut agir et agir fortement et
rapidement
on a besoin de s'appuyer sur les
collectivités avec cette fois cet
échange proximité mais du coup il y a
besoin d'avoir cette ingénierie et cet
appui à l'échelle à l'échelle locale
donc ça je pense que c'est quelque chose
qui est qui est assez qui est assez
clair après moi j'avais plusieurs
plusieurs questions c'est vrai que dans
le dispositif actuel tel qu'il est mis
en place et tel qui il entrain encore
d'évoluer mais en tout cas tel qu'il
fonctionne c'est vrai qu'on s'aperçoit
que le bilan qu'on a pu faire c'est que
on est beaucoup sur du monogest
alors bon plutôt sur du changement de
chaudière ou des ou des choses des
choses comme ça qui sont liées en fait
aux aides qui sont attribués aussi aux
démarchage qui peut y avoir et
donc voilà ma première question c'était
de savoir comment on se fait selon vous
on pouvait arriver à avoir un dispositif
justement qui s'extrait un peu justement
de cette question des mots de gestes
pour aller plutôt vers de la rénovation
globale
même si en soi c'est pas forcément
d'aller tout de suite sur de la
rénovation globale mais en tout cas que
le premier geste il soit fait en
connaissance de cause et que ça soit le
bon premier geste à dire donc voir un
petit peu comment du coup voilà vous
puisque ce que vous ce que vous aviez
comme comme idée sur sur une évolution
pour aller plutôt là-dessus alors il y
avait la question du du passeport
logement ou en tout cas de problème de
santé enfin voilà en tout cas qui fait
que on puisse avoir une une vraie
visibilité sur sur l'évolution du des
logements et puis du coup des
interventions successives
donc ouais ça m'intéressait d'avoir
votre avis là dessus ensuite il y avait
la question de mon accompagnateur Renov
donc pareil donc qui va être mis en
place et
voir comment en fait vous l'envisagez
notamment enfin sur le réseau flamme et
sur les Alex c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose
qui pour beaucoup fonctionné déjà enfin
dire en tout cas il y avait justement à
la fois cette porte d'entrée à la fois
cet accompagnement
qui est qui était fait localement
comment vous comment vous le voyez
est-ce que pour vous c'est quelque chose
qui va venir remplacer le travail qui
était déjà fait quand on a des
plateformes de rénovation ou des ou des
Alex sur place est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qui peut être complémentaire en
tout cas comment comment vous
l'envisagez en tout cas dans sa mise
dans sa mise en place
ensuite oui et puis du coup notre
question était sur la question peut-être
des inégalités qui peut y avoir entre
territoires
parce que vous avez dit que là par
exemple on a 40 40 allègues en France
bon il y a d'autres dispositifs mais on
sait qu'il y a des territoires sur
lequel il y a pas grand chose qui est
qui existe
la compagnateur rénov peut être une
réponse mais du coup sur cette question
un peu des d'égalité territoriales
comment vous voyez ça et puis une
dernière question sur la sur les
filières
à la fois sur l'accompagnement des des
entreprises
formation
mais aussi sur la mise en place de
filières alors là peut-être plutôt vers
le serema sur sur les questions de
nouveaux matériaux matériaux biosourcés
la mise en place de filières de filières
locales c'est vrai qu'on voit que ça
commence déjà enfin ça se développe déjà
ça commence à émerger après il y a le
lien à la fois sur la question de norme
es etc mais c'est pareil pour mettre ça
en place sur un territoire bah ça
demande une ingénierie assez importante
et donc voilà la question était de
savoir si un vous aviez déjà des
exemples en tout cas de d'accompagnement
et qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire
justement pour aller plus vite sur ce
dans ce domaine là voilà merci
[Musique]
merci je vais peut-être pour commencer
par rapport à la problématique monogèse
versus voilà rénovation globale une
première chose qui qu'on pourrait faire
c'est éviter que quand on fait du
monogest on fasse les monogestes dans le
mauvais sens c'est à dire ne pas
subventionner le financement d'un
changement de système de chauffage si le
bâtiment n'a pas été isolé d'abord parce
que faire à la limite on faire
l'isolation enfin faire le projet de
rénovation en plusieurs étapes pourquoi
pas force si on peut le faire en une
étape ça sera toujours mieux mais c'est
pas toujours possible c'est pas voilà et
donc mais au moins que que le processus
soit fait dans le bon sens et d'abord
isoler l'enveloppe pour réduire les
consommations ensuite changer le système
de chauffage pour ne pas mettre en place
un système de chauffage surdimensionné
si on fait dans mauvais sens et donc
voilà on peut faire par étape mais le
tout c'est de ne pas de ne pas
subventionner des étapes dans mauvais
sens parce que là c'est de l'argent du
gaspiller quoi clairement
ensuite peut-être je continue pour le
marc oui alors en fait mon
accompagnateur rénove ce qu'on pense
c'est qu'il faut qu'il soit
complémentaire de ce qui existe
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que ce qu'on
demande c'est que dans le service public
la rénovation le Conseil France rénov ce
qu'il faut on pense indispensable c'est
que non seulement il est l'information
et le conseil personnalisé mais il est
indispensable que il est ce suivi tout
au long du projet c'est à dire que même
si le ménage fait appel à une assistance
à maîtrise d'ouvrages qu'on appelle Marc
aujourd'hui avec un cahier des charges
bien défini n'empêche que il faut que le
particulier puisse à tout moment se
retourner vers vers son service public
de confiance et en cas de problème en
cas de questions voilà qui puisse à tout
moment être là et puis le mon
accompagnateur énorme c'est quand même
quelque chose de lourd qui coûte cher
donc qui est aujourd'hui en ce qui est
prévu c'est que ça soit pour les projets
vraiment les projets ambitieux avec au
moins 10000 euros d'aide voilà mais
n'empêche que les autres projets qui ne
rentrent pas dans ce cadre là
les particuliers ont peut-être quand
même besoin d'un niveau d'accompagnement
mais qui peut être moindre n'a pas
forcément besoin de d'aller à ce niveau
de l'accompagnement mais et ça ça
devrait pouvoir être fait dans le cadre
du service public en fait globalement
c'est ce que font les PTR enfin ce que
faisaient les PT RRE voilà donc c'est un
niveau d'accompagnement qui peut être
voilà pas forcément besoin d'un audit à
chaque fois voilà on peut on n'est pas
obligé d'aller si loin dans
l'accompagnement mais n'empêche qu'il
faut que ça République il soit il puisse
faire cet accompagnement peut-être
minimum et puis dans les cas complexes
dans les cas où effectivement il y a le
gros travaux menés à ce moment-là aller
plus loin et effectivement avoir cette
amo sur l'appelez comme ça mon époque
c'est de la moelle donc et cette amo
elle peut elle est comme c'est prévu
elle va être dans le champ concurrentiel
donc mais il faut que le service public
puisse soit là à chaque fois entière de
confiance vis-à-vis des particuliers
donc voilà c'est un peu comme ça qu'on
qu'on
souhaiterait que évolue le service
public en fait
je rajouterai sans parler donc du marc
et de la complexité que ça peut apporter
pour rebondir ce qu'a dit Monsieur Berto
il a nécessité des mesures ça rejoint un
petit peu ce qui a évoqué monsieur
sentier c'est à dire prioriser dans un
ordre cohérent ce que l'on fait je vous
donne un exemple du coup je prends ma
casquette délurétionnelle j'étais en
charge la performance énergétique des
lycées et on a commencé par instrumenter
les lycées parce qu'il fallait qu'on ait
une mesure de référence de base pour
savoir si toutes les actions que nous
allions mener dans nos lycées allez nous
permettre d'atteindre la
neutralité carbone à 2050 en fait on est
parti de l'objectif et on a fait un
rétroplanning pour savoir d'abord donc
fallait instrumenter les lycées sont à
plus de 50% instrumentés nous avons
ensuite travaillé sur l'efficacité
énergétique des lycées donc vraiment sur
la rénovation même s'il reste un petit
peu quelques points noirs lorsque les
rénovations étaient moins
ressentent que d'autres parce que nous
avions des lycées qui ont plus d'un
siècle il faut le savoir donc
lorsqu'elles étaient moins importantes
on y a collé aussi la substitution
systématique par des ENR c'est à dire
qu'on était dans une progression pour
rentrer dans une rénovation du bâtiment
extrêmement performant ce qui nous a
permis quand même d'avoir des résultats
conséquents puisque entre 2000 et 2023
nous avons versé de 40% les émissions
qu'elles effets de serre qui était donc
instrumentés et mesuré depuis les années
2000 donc c'est pour ça que ce que
disait monsieur sentier c'est très
important de porter graduellement et de
prioriser les actions de rénovation si
on veut vraiment répondre à ces
réductions de consommation comme des
missions de gaz à effet de serre sur les
structurations de filières je pense que
le c'est le rôle à mon sens des régions
de de proposer et d'organiser ces
structurations nous c'est ce qui a été
le cas en nouvelle-aquitaine on a
structuré la fil première chambre et la
filière paille donc aujourd'hui nous
sommes en mesure de proposer grâce à un
guide environnemental extrêmement
rigoureux et pointu des matériaux
bio-sourcés lorsqu'on fait de la
rénovation c'est à dire qu'on
systématiquement on va étudier la
possibilité de mettre des matériaux sur
C que peuvent être les le chanvre le
béton de champ vous la paille donc c'est
les régions un rôle d'animation vraiment
pour créer ces filières ces structures
et ses filières parallèlement à ça les
régions aussi ont un rôle et je pense
qu'il faut vraiment les motiver
là-dessus sur la formation
professionnelle parce que on a quand
même des gros soucis sur
le enfin comment dire sur les
professionnels du bâtiment ou des fois
puisqu'on parlait de matériaux des
co-matériaux lorsqu'il y a une
méconnaissance de l'usage de
l'utilisation de ces de ces échos
matériaux on n'a pas les résultats
escomptés mais tout ça c'est parce que
la mise en œuvre a pas été faite dans
les règles donc la formation formation
profession personnel la structuration de
filière tout ça je pense que c'est de
l'ordre vraiment de d'impulsion des
régions voilà on a besoin aussi de
effectivement de former plus de
personnes on voit qu'aujourd'hui surtout
le recrutement c'est très compliqué quoi
c'est pas que dans les Alecs
de formation aussi bien initiale que
continuent en fait
Monsieur le Directeur général sur les
questions de financement
la bonne nouvelle c'est que
effectivement
les travaux qu'on veut arriver à ce
qu'il se fasse produisent effectivement
une diminution de la facture énergétique
donc il y a il y a des gains potentiels
la difficulté effectivement c'est
comment les activer pour arriver
effectivement à faire les travaux
nous on est totalement en phase avec ce
qui a été dit c'est-à-dire que il faut
faire dans l'ordre d'abord commencer
effectivement par faire ce qui coûte pas
cher et c'est vrai que pour l'instant
nos programmes cubes on a réussi à les
faire fonctionner vraiment très bien
dans le dans le tertiaire on commence
sur le logement donc il y a probablement
à apprendre à trouver mais il nous
semble que c'est effectivement déjà la
première des choses à faire c'est ce
qu'on peut faire qui coûte pas cher
après évidemment
on vous rejoint tout à fait il faut
clairement avoir des projets un peu
globaux et c'est vrai qu'il y a sûrement
un grand intérêt à activer les économies
qui peuvent être faites pour financer
alors à travers des processus de tir
financement à travers des processus de
contrats de performance énergétique il y
a aujourd'hui les outils existent y
compris le tiers financement
comment dire étendu très opportunément
aux collectivités il y a une dizaine de
jours
voilà donc il faut travailler là-dessus
simplement faut avoir en tête que
évidemment c'est des sujets qui au terme
de technique financières si j'ose dire
sont plus compliquées que ce qu'on avait
l'habitude de faire jusqu'à présent et
ce qui renvoie immédiatement évidemment
à des questions de formation de voilà
donc ce travail là enfin je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les outils de fait
existent ou en tout cas sont pas très
loin d'exister il y a probablement
beaucoup à travailler sur encore une
fois la formation des accompagnateurs je
reviens moi je suis là c'est tout à fait
d'accord et ce qui était sur les
accompagnateurs ce qu'on voit c'est que
au fond la situation elle est elle est
assez simple on a des maîtres d'ouvrage
qui qui soient d'ailleurs entreprises
collectivités ou particuliers qui sont
pas et c'est normal sont pas compétents
sur ces sujets là et donc c'est vrai que
la notion d'accompagnateur nous nous
sommes vraiment une très bonne chose
parce que c'est les prendre par la main
alors c'est pas faire la place
évidemment le job de l'accompagnateur il
sera pas le même quand on est sur un
office de HLM qui a les moyens Léa ou
quand on est sur le particulier ou le
groupe des trois ou quatre particuliers
mais mais clairement je crois que c'est
là effectivement qu'on arrivera à faire
basculer la chose parce que
objectivement les mecs d'ouvrage ils
sont tout seul quoi et c'est des sujets
qui ne connaissent pas et donc voilà
donc ça ça nous paraît assez assez
j'allais dire assez facilement c'est pas
forcément le mot mais en tout cas on
voit bien ce qu'il faut faire on voit
bien ce qu'il faut faire la difficulté
et l'ex est assez massif la formation
massive je rejoins tout à fait ce que
vous disiez sur l'artisans etc donc il y
a un effort massif de monter en
compétences à la fois des
accompagnateurs concrets à la fois des
entreprises et puis effectivement il y a
les nouvelles filières peut-être la
navette de passer la parole là dessus
sur laquelle nous on s'est pas mal
investi sur les vidéos matériaux et on
voit là aussi que
typiquement vous situiez région
Aquitaine mais dans d'autres régions
aussi on voit que les choses commencent
à être mûr mais là aussi il va y avoir
un gros effort de promotion etc et tout
d'abord de formation effectivement avec
la spécificité concernant évidemment les
les filières locales et les matériaux
biosourcés par exemple sur lesquels
effectivement le serrer ma travail c'est
la dimension locale la dimension locale
sous plusieurs angles bien sûr sous
l'angle déjà climatique puisque
forcément une rénovation énergétique ne
va pas s'abonner de la même manière
selon le territoire l'évolution
climatique n'est pas la même non plus
bien sûr on a des tendances
patrimoniales qui sont pas toutes mais
qui devraient théoriquement être en
harmonie aussi avec ces conditions
locales ce qui est pas forcément le cas
mais en tout cas on y a des grandes
tendances de typologie patrimoniale
globale qui requiert justement aussi à
avoir définir qui soit en adéquation sur
la rénovation alors sur la construction
bien sûr ils vont travailler deux fois
sur les matériaux biosourcés pour les
nouvelles constructions mais également
pour la rénovation donc par exemple
là-dessus nous on a on a monté en
partenariat le centre de ressources de
la réhabilitation responsable sur le
bâti ancien le kreba qui permet
justement d'apporter de des sources
d'information sur l'ensemble des
ressources et des matériaux et déjà des
filières qui sont à l'oeuvre on a coupé
ça avec aussi un travail en d'autres
partenaires sur avec un observatoire des
coûts de la construction sur les
matériaux aussi bio sur C qui peuvent
être du coup réutilisés à ce niveau là
et des actions autour qui sont bien sûr
à ce stade de la forme
forcément la formation à proprement dit
mais déjà de la sensibilisation au
niveau des maîtres d'ouvrage des maîtres
d'oeuvre des architectes bien sûr et des
artisans
tout ça prend deux prend deux aspects
donc il y a effectivement le la partie
la partie de mise en place de filières
locales à la fois construct donc 9 est
réhabilitation mais aussi sur la partie
matériaux comme on vient de l'évoquer
typiquement les matériaux sourcés nos
études aussi pour que là-dessus en lien
aussi avec l'université gustaveyssem sur
les effets justement favorables en
termes de décarbonation au-delà de
performance qui sur la sur la thermique
bien sûr mais aussi sur l'acoustique
donc sur toutes ces filières on a déjà
des choses qui sont valorisables qui
sont valorisées avec aussi des chantiers
vitrines qui sont structurés un peu
partout on peut pas parler aussi par
exemple le localement en Isère de la
terre crue qui est qui est en train de
se structurer pour une partie aussi du
département en tout cas une conviction
de de nos travaux et nous
accompagnements c'est que c'est vraiment
au niveau local alors est-ce que
l'échelle régionale est pertinent pour
avoir une vue d'ensemble mais il y a
encore des disparités aussi ensuite à
l'intérieur mais sur l'aspect aussi
formation sur sur tous ces
structurations économiques et de
formation qui est quand même la base
c'est l'échelle pertinente ensuite sur
la déclinaison et spécificités il y a
sans doute des échelles intermédiaires
au niveau bien sûr des collectivités
locales en partenariat à mettre en
oeuvre mais donc oui nous sommes
convaincus qu'il faut aussi accélérer
là-dessus et c'est le pendant justement
qui permettra d'avoir aussi des
rénovations énergétiques réussie que se
fasse dans un ensemble rapide ou qu'elle
se fasse étape par étape bien sûr on la
planifiant comme on vient de l'évoquer
dans le propos précédent
bien sûr
complémentaire par rapport à ce que
sur la question des matériaux biosourcés
donc toujours intérêt en termes
d'utilisation de filière etc et savoir
si en même temps sur la question du
stockage carbone puisque du coup c'est
aussi un moyen assez intéressant de
stocker du carbone pour un certain temps
est-ce que ça aussi vous enfin c'est
quelque chose qui est pris en compte et
qui pourrait du coup
venir rendre quoi en tout cas favoriser
encore plus ce type de ce type de
matériel
et quand on peut allier l'ensemble c'est
les recherches sur les matériaux sont
aussi sous cet angle sachant qu'en plus
selon les territoires effectivement les
matériaux locaux qui peuvent permettre
d'atteindre à la fois cette performance
dans la rénovation énergétique mais
aussi de faire également du stockage
carbone voilà ne sont pas les mêmes donc
les territoires sont aussi négaux par
rapport à ça donc il faut aussi d'avoir
en tête j'avais oublié de le dire
précédemment
juste ajouter quelque chose par rapport
à en fait c'était mentionné comme ça on
a des des nouveaux matériaux qui
arrivent etc et ce qui est important
c'est de faire savoir ce qui que ça
existe de faire savoir que qu'il y a des
mises en œuvre qui sont faites et donc
en fait de faire de faire connaître via
des visites de sites etc donc ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est qui fait
partie aussi le fait d'animer d'un fort
de sensibiliser par des visites de sites
c'est quelque chose de très important
qui doit être fait localement aussi ça
doit être faire partie aussi du service
public d'ailleurs pour pour c'est un
moyen de faire rentrer les gens dans
dans une démarche qui pourra aboutir on
espère à la rénovation de leur logement
mais de commencer par aussi bien les les
faire travailler sur effectivement sur
de la sensibilité enfin sur des
problèmes de de la sobriété énergétique
donc au niveau des Alecs et des espaces
faut énergies il y avait des des défis
qui étaient mis en place on appelait
famille énergie positive à l'époque
ensuite voilà donc c'est des choses qui
se font depuis longtemps en fait
justement pour encourager les les
économies et puis voilà faire savoir
montrer ce qui se fait pour donner envie
en fait c'est important et c'est valable
pour les citoyens mais c'est valable
pour les collectivités également faire
visiter des des écoles rénovées à la
collectivité d'à côté ça fait partie des
choses qui qui sont faites et qui
doivent être vraiment être faites c'est
important
une des axes qui fait partie du cœur de
notre métier c'est vraiment les échanges
d'expériences énormément l'animation et
l'information et faire passer ses
messages là parce que autant dit souvent
il n'y a qu'un élu qui peut convaincre
un autre élu mais là c'est pareil il n'y
a que entre professionnels si on peut
les amener sur des sites des chantiers
école sur lesquels on aille innover avec
des nouveaux matériaux c'est ça qui
pourra convaincre en fait aussi pour
finir aussi concernant vraiment
l'ingénierie territoriale locale que les
élus ont vraiment dans les élus ont
vraiment besoin sur leur territoire
j'ai fait une proposition il y a enfin
février au ministère de des comptes
publics pour faire une proposition de
financement de cette ingénierie dès lors
qu'elle est mutualisée à travers un
budget annexe qui devrait être initié
par l'État et qui devrait se décliner
donc à l'échelle de chacune des
intercommunalités avec cette petite
contrainte dans le cadre de ce budget de
pouvoir créer des enfin pas tout voir
mais d'être contraint du coup de créer
une ingénierie mutualisée parce qu'il
faut avoir vraiment une vision globale
qui ne s'arrête pas alors déjà une
vision globale sur son territoire à
l'échelle intercommunale mais aussi une
vision encore plus élargie puisqu'il
peut y avoir des passerelles qui sont
forcément à créer entre le rural et
l'urbain par exemple entre les
producteurs et les consommateurs on va
dire aussi en termes d'énergie donc
c'est ça ça permet justement ces
échanges forts et d'être pertinents en
tout cas sur sur la production d'énergie
et aussi sur les rénovations
des bâtiments j'ai fait aussi valoir que
il faut parce que ce que l'on nous
renvoie souvent c'est que en termes
d'ingénierie à côté c'est nouveau
budgets de fonctionnement et là ça
hérisse le poil de beaucoup de monde et
ce que j'ai fait valoir et par une de
nos agences c'est en fait nos
conseillers lorsqu'ils travaillent sur
le Conseil justement des particuliers et
des entreprises puisque j'avais ce que
ces deux changes j'avais pas sur les
collectivités quel chiffre d'affaires
ils ont généré donc ces conseillers ils
génèrent entre trois et quatre millions
de chiffre d'affaires sur le territoire
mais ça je pense qu'il faut que l'État
puisse l'entendre parce que s'il finance
plus il le sait en fait j'allais dire
c'est une un cercle vertueux plus il va
financer de façon simple les
collectivités pour se doter d'ingénierie
plus il va les récupérer grâce à
l'attractivité qui va qui va être mise
en oeuvre sur les territoires donc c'est
un petit peu voilà attractivité
rénovation
initiation de de
la TVA c'est de nouveau dans les caisses
de l'État qu'elle va repartir donc je
trouve que c'est pas un format cette
ingénierie de de comment dire de quelque
chose qui est passif qui est pas
productif c'est pas du c'est quelque
chose qui va justement générer ce sont
des apporteurs d'affaires je devrais pas
dire ce terme puisque c'est du champ du
service public que je défends
profondément mais ce sont quand même des
apporteurs d'affaires au bénéfice de
leur territoire et de l'état aussi je
suis le directeur général
un complément sur ces questions
d'ingénierie je pense qu'effectivement
il faut raisonner vraiment dans la
complémentarité entre ce que peut faire
le privé et ce que doit faire le public
nous on a beaucoup travaillé là-dessus
parce que c'était évidemment une des
craintes des bureaux d'études privées en
disant mais enfin on crée le céréma ça
va nous bouffer de la LED sur le dos etc
pour tout vous dire aujourd'hui on a
représentant de sa tête ingénérique et
dans notre conseil d'administration on a
une convention avec synthèque ingénierie
une convention avec synov donc on a
justement essayé vraiment de jouer cette
complémentarité publique privée parce
que finalement on voit bien que il y a
des choses que le privé en fait ne peut
pas faire et notamment auprès des
collectivités tout ce qui est à la boue
et au moment où quelque chose qui est
collectivités c'est pas vraiment ce
qu'elle veut aller s'adresser à un privé
voilà ça peut donner des trucs un peu
bizarres les débats sur les cabinets de
conseil non non mais c'est exactement ça
en fait c'est exactement ça le sujet et
donc du coup ce qui est assez marrant
c'est qu'en fait cette discussion là on
l'a eu avec les représentants du bureau
d'études privées et ils ont fini par
dire que c'était assez d'accord
notamment en posant une question toute
bête qui était voilà on a supprimé la
tzat il y a 10 ou 15 ans quel a été
l'évolution de votre chiffre d'affaires
il a baissé c'est assez spectaculaire
quand même et c'est logique parce que
les collectivités elles avaient pu
auprès d'elle les gens pour préparer les
appels d'offres les marchés donc donc il
faut arriver à recréer quelque chose
évidemment pas la tézat tout ce qu'on
pouvait faire moi moi j'ai commencé car
il y a 35 ans à la grande époque où
voilà on faisait des travaux pour les
collectivités donc évidemment pas ça
mais clairement justement sur ces
fonctions ou clairement le privé peut
pas assumer
notamment à faire augmenter assez
fortement notre activité de formation à
la fois d'ailleurs pour les
collectivités et effectivement pour les
pour les bureaux privés parce que
quelque part on réussira que si on
arrive à mobiliser l'ensemble de la
communauté
je sais pas s'il y a des collègues qui
souhaitent nous poser des questions moi
je voudrais simplement me poser une
question plus particulièrement sur
le guichet unique on a auditionné la
semaine dernière le secrétaire à la
planification écologique qui nous a
annoncé le déploiement de guichet unique
pour l'accueil et l'orientation à
l'échelle de chaque PCI d'ici 2025 quel
est votre votre sentiment votre avis
là-dessus voilà
il en était question effectivement ce
matin en fait la grosse question à se
poser c'est qu'est-ce qu'on met derrière
le mot guichet voilà ça je crois que
c'est le préalable et c'est ce sur quoi
nous allons nous pencher à travers les
groupes de travail qu'à proposer Simon
Yvetot ce matin justement donc c'est
déjà se dire qu'est-ce qu'on met
derrière la notion de guichet déjà et
comment on l'envisage parce que ce que
j'expliquais aussi ce matin notamment
monsieur Yvetot c'est que
on peut avoir des idées ou des principes
des supers principes et de bonnes idées
de politiques publiques mais si on ne
parallèlement ne met pas on ne réfléchit
pas assez en amont sur la mise en oeuvre
sur les modalités de mise en œuvre ça
peut échouer alors que le principe ou
l'idée peut être bonne au départ donc
c'est pour ça que ce guichet unique il
faut voir d'abord qu'est-ce qu'on y met
derrière et comment aussi on va pouvoir
le déployer puisqu'il a parlé
il a et je confirme donc l'échelle des
EPCI mais comment en faire bénéficier
aussi la petite commune qui a une heure
de route de l'EPCI et et ses citoyens
ses habitants donc tout ça c'est
envisagé c'est pour ça que la modalité
la mise en oeuvre elle est tout aussi
importante que l'idée de guichet qui est
une très bonne idée aux par ailleurs
mais savoir qu'est-ce qu'on met derrière
et puis en fait avoir un guichet au
niveau de chaque PCI ça veut pas
forcément dire avoir une structure au
niveau de chaque EPCI en fait c'est là
qu'on peut effectivement dans les
territoires ruraux à nouveau il faut
mutualiser mais en fait bon par exemple
les Alecs ils sont dans les territoires
ruraux sont souvent l'échelons
départementales elles ont des
permanences des mairies voilà elle
tourne dans les différents mairies pour
être présente au plus près mais
évidemment elles sont pas tous les jours
dans la mairie du petit villagement elle
se déplace de façon à pouvoir courir
tout le territoire et être présente
localement quoi et du coup ça a permis
aussi de créer des liens avec les
maisons France services qui au départ
tout le monde se regardait un petit peu
un chien de faïence
je m'en découle un petit peu mais non
finalement ça se passe très très bien et
les permanences qui sont faites dans ces
lieux là du coup ça crée une vraiment
une dynamique au sein de la petite
collectivité rurale et c'est vraiment
super et l'articulation avec France
rénov oui c'est le ça sera enfin je
pense que le guichet unique l'entrée
sera déconseillée France rénov à mon
avis mais après voilà on est au tout
départ on est sur une feuille blanche là
pour l'instant oui après Franck montogy
souhaite poser une question allez-y
monsieur non sur cette question là nous
effectivement sur la même ligne assez
favorable à une vision du guichet unique
qui soit un petit peu un point d'entrée
unique c'est vrai qu'on l'a évoqué tous
les deux il y a une grande complexité
alors on peut penser que on réduira la
complexité en faisant un machin je veux
voir qu'une seule tête etc la réalité
c'est que la grande complexité elle a
des raisons et que le jour où on va
vouloir arriver à simplifier on aura
beaucoup de mal par contre
l'idée de mettre des intermédiaires si
j'ose dire effectivement proche du
terrain qui connaissent cette complexité
et qui puisse dire à un élu étant
décimaux de sujet c'est ça voilà on va
appeler monsieur machin à tel endroit
parce que c'est lui qui va pouvoir vous
aider etc on va appeler Madame truc
voilà et ça ça je pense effectivement ça
apportera énormément par contre si on
essaye d'avoir un système centralisé
c'est une question qu'on a souvent comme
opérateur mais alors le serrer maladem
la NCT le machin bien sûr que si on
construisait les choses à partir de zéro
aujourd'hui on construitait pas du tout
les choses telles qu'elles sont là parce
qu'elles sont héritées de l'histoire
comment c'est tout à l'heure on vous
disant qu'on avait plus de 2000 ans
d'histoire donc voilà mais en réalité
petit à petit les choses peuvent évoluer
c'est la preuve on a fusionner aux
entités mais tout ça ne peut se faire
que dans le temps et le problème c'est
qu'on a pas le temps d'attendre donc
effectivement des solutions de type
point d'entrée unique qui permet de
redispatier de d'aider finalement les
collectivités à se mouvoir dans ce
labyrinthe c'est faisable j'allais
relativement facilement relativement
rapidement et pour le coup ça aura je
pense un grand intérêt très vite pour
tout le monde quoi
alors franchement toget
présidente merci à vous quatre pour vous
présenterai justement une question à
vous poser par rapport à ce qui
s'appelait à l'époque je crois que
c'était issu de la loi de transition
énergétique donc après de 10 ans les PT
RRE les plateformes territoriales de
rénovation énergétique qui répondait en
réalité oriente voilà des choses qui
existaient déjà en tout cas dans
l'esprit qui avait vocation donc à jouer
le rôle de guichet unique est-ce que
vous avez pu observer
des petre fonctionnaient
voilà est-ce qu'elle fonctionne toujours
pour certaines d'entre elles et est-ce
que d'autres se sont arrêtés et si oui
pour qu'elle pour quelle raison et puis
finalement est-ce qu'il faut pas est-ce
qu'il faut passer inspirer des démarches
de ce type là qui ont fonctionné qui
existent toujours
les complétant certainement de ce qu'il
faut pour actualiser les les
services qui sont rendus aux politiques
politiques actuelles merci
énergétique avec les entrées des anciens
conseillers qui sont assez fermes et
puis maintenant France rénov puisque
c'est une continuité existe toujours le
souci c'est qu'à l'échelle d'un
territoire même régional toutes les EPCI
ne se sont pas dotés de ptae et ce dont
on a besoin c'est que les politiques
énergétiques que l'on met en oeuvre au
niveau national il faut qu'elle soit
déployée à toutes les échelles mais
surtout que toutes les échelles puissant
saisir et pourquoi elles n'ont pas été
parfois et pourquoi elle se sent aussi
arrêtées c'est une question souvent de
financement quand les financements
s'arrêtent les aides s'arrêtent et c'est
là où on voit que
à certains endroits les collectivités
peut-être pas forcément dans une
véritable démarche de rentrer dans ces
plateformes de rénovation et que c'était
juste le temps de de l'opportunité d'une
aide d'État notamment et régional aussi
il faut le savoir donc voilà mais l'idée
c'est que là c'est d'instoring guichet
unique dans tous les EPCI et c'est ça
qu'il faut parce que c'est ça qui
combattra aussi les inégalités
territoriales mais là il faut y mettre
les moyens de toute façon si on ne met
pas les moyens voilà c'est compliqué il
y a beaucoup beaucoup d'alegues portent
des PTA en fait et ça a été une
évolution finalement il y avait les
Espaces Info Énergie et du conseil et
puis on a eu les ptao qui permettait de
faire justement une forme
d'accompagnement et puis là finalement
le France rénov c'est ça avec mon
accompagnateur et là où on a l'idée
c'était de dire dans certains cas il
faut un accompagnement plus boosté plus
poussé et donc on veut le mettre sous
forme du Naïm d'une vraie amo qui
s'appelle mon accompagnateur énorme mais
en fait voilà tout ça c'est des choses
qui sont déjà qui existent déjà sur les
territoires alors après c'est
aujourd'hui selon les territoires il y a
des terribles il y a peu enfin l'ADEM
dit dans le programme star et à peu près
tout est couvert alors c'est ça peut
être couvert à différents niveaux en
fait les endroits où c'est juste de
l'info conseil par téléphone
le choix où il y a de l'info au conseil
avec des présences physiques et puis des
fois où il y a il y a le niveau
effectivement d'accompagnement qui qui
est présent donc mais aujourd'hui c'est
pas complètement homogène partout mais
il y a un tous les cas il y a déjà une
base et dans beaucoup de territoires
quoi et avec effectivement ce qu'il y a
c'est qu'aujourd'hui il y a des c'est
porté par des structures différentes
parfois se porter en régie directement
par les EPCI parfois se porter par des
Alecs parfois c'est porté par des
associations voilà on a on a une divers
assez grande diversité de
[Musique]
mise en oeuvre aujourd'hui
à cette affaire les régions voir les
départements etc vous y croyez la notion
de guichet unique il faut qu'il
fonctionne oui je pense que oui je pense
que oui et ce qu'il faut c'est que
chaque niveau institutionnel se saisisse
de l'enjeu chacun de par ses compétences
qu'ils ont aujourd'hui
c'est ça
[Musique]
en fait le problème c'est que le mot
guichet unique peut avoir de multiples
sens et c'est vrai que souvent enfin on
le voit quand on dit voilà c'est
l'endroit où on va tout faire etc mais
c'est évident que ça on y arrivera pas
par contre si on dit il y a moi
j'appelle ça un réducteur de complexité
d'une certaine façon c'est effectivement
un endroit où on intègre toute la
complexité des aides des actions des uns
et des autres et on est capable de
parler simplement à un citoyen en disant
voilà si votre problème c'est ça en fait
votre interlocuteur c'est ça pour faire
ça voilà c'est c'est pour moi le guichet
unique c'est ça en fait c'est cette
capacité
à intégrer la complexité et à ressortir
une réponse simple citoyen parce que
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je suis
d'accord que c'est quand même compliqué
en fait si on veut
mettez ton micro Franck s'il te plaît
avec un point qui me paraît assez
essentiel dans cette complexité c'est
que il y a un suivi du demandeur de A à
Z c'est à dire que si on l'envoie à tel
interlocuteur puis après à tel autre il
y a une vision globale de son parcours
et qui se perdent pas quoi qu'on le
perdent pas qu'il est au bout du compte
une réponse voilà au problème
quitte à ce que le problème il soit
reformulé
dans le parcours quoi est-ce que je veux
dire par rapport aux besoins réels
guichet unique ce qu'il y a d'importance
c'est de recréer de la confiance auprès
de nos concitoyens ils sont tellement
démarchés de part et d'autre que si
jamais ils ont des questions d'ordre de
rénovation quelques niveaux que ce soit
une entreprise ou une collectivité une
petite commune elle va dans ce guichet
unique et ce comme disait monsieur
Bertaud ce guichet son rôle après va
être de réorienter vers le bon
interlocuteur mais en sachant que
passant passant par ce prisme là il aura
une réponse vraiment attendue à sa
question et elle sera fiable et créer et
il faut recréer cette confiance là parce
que je pense qu'elle a été perdue par
cette multiplicité d'intervenants en
fait oui oui
c'est un peu du niveau d'État mais
j'essaie vraiment vous l'avez compris de
me placer du point de vue des
usagers
le numérique que je suppose va jouer une
rôle important c'est à faire là tel
qu'elle se profile il n'y a pas de
réseau c'est le cas pour d'autres sujets
il y a pas de raison que ça ne soit pas
pour celui-là voilà j'attire à
l'attention sur
la question de l'accès au numérique
avec le directeur développement durable
de Schneider
electricité
sur certaines territoires où les
populations sont en moyenne plutôt plus
âgées qu'ailleurs le rapport le rapport
à l'informatique au plateforme il va
être il va être crucial donc c'est aussi
un aspect en fait les plateformes
numériques elle peut servir
effectivement à l'usager et ça peut être
un point d'entrée mais enfin il faut
comme il faut de physique tout le monde
ne peut pas s'en servir donc il est
important d'avoir des présences
physiques ça c'est capital mais l'outil
numérique qui sert aussi justement aux
parties prenantes
je suis beaucoup plus sur le peut-être
sur enfin
le numérique si c'est bien utilisé ça
peut être un vrai réducteur de
complexité je dis pour le coup
effectivement mais mais évidemment ça
remplacera jamais le fait d'avoir
quelqu'un donc c'est un outil qui permet
de faire de la de complexité mais voilà
et puis le deuxième point je voulais
évoquer c'est c'est vrai que derrière si
on veut sécuriser les citoyens enfin on
voit que c'est bien le sujet ça veut
dire qu'il va falloir aller assez loin y
compris dans la labellisation des
entreprises dire qu'on échappera pas à
mon sens à un moment à labellisé les
entreprises et être capable de dire à
quelqu'un c'est là vous pouvez y aller
celle-là vaut mieux pas alors évidemment
jamais la puissance publique peut dire
les choses comme ça la labellisation
c'est une façon de c'est une façon de le
faire mais voilà c'est
parce que c'est vrai que on l'a peut
évoquer mais aujourd'hui c'est quand
même c'est hallucinant enfin vous avez
des margoulins un peu partout bah c'est
et ça a vachement décrédibiliser parce
que les gens ils ont peur mais c'est
pour ça quand même que ce qu'on dit fin
sur le guichet unique il y a plein de
gros ça existe déjà enfin je veux dire
ce fonctionnement là sur le fait en tout
cas il y a des collectivités qui ont mis
en place des plateformes de rénovation
sur lequel on s'adresse
une personne en tout cas voilà avec un
accompagnement avec une orientation avec
des conseils sur des entreprises et du
coup un réseau local donc en fait ça
c'est quelque chose qui existe déjà
après la vraie question c'est comment
généralise en fait c'est comment on
arrive à faire en sorte qu'on est à peu
près à l'échelle du territoire
à l'échelle nationale un système qui
soit à peu près à peu près cohérent mais
en fait ça ça montre en tout cas que ça
fonctionne parce que dans les endroits
où c'est mis en place c'est plutôt assez
efficace c'est surtout aussi qu'est-ce
que va mettre derrière ce mot le
ministère c'est surtout ça puisqu'ils
veulent revoir le contenu de
ce qu'on parlait du numérique mais c'est
pas tout à fait le numérique d'en parler
Franck c'est vrai aussi que hier on a eu
le directeur du développement durable de
Schneider Electric par rapport aux
solutions
mettent en place aux technologies et
donc lui il montrait aussi combien le
numérique aujourd'hui est un outil pour
s'inscrire dans la sobriété énergétique
quelque part dire ce que vous disiez au
début c'est à dire que d'abord des
comportements d'usage et à travers le
numérique et relativement des
applications qui sont faciles à mettre
en place que dans tout le monde peut se
saisir qui permettent déjà de prendre
conscience
de la consommation ou en tout cas des
économies potentielles que l'on peut
être amené à faire par de simples gestes
voilà donc c'était aussi ça
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres questions oui
Sabine
oui alors en fait on parlait tout à
l'heure des matériaux locaux et bio
sourcés finalement sont ceux avec
lesquels on construisait il y a 300 ans
200 ans et j'aimerais savoir si vous
avez le sentiment que les enjeux de
protection du bâti patrimonial qui a une
valeur architecturale ou historique
c'est spécificités aussi en termes
d'hygrohermie sans suffisamment connu et
pris en compte dans le DPE et dans les
préconisations de travaux qui ont
découle
précisément par rapport au dépe je
saurais pas me prononcer personnellement
par contre oui la prise en compte est là
et effectivement c'est pour ça aussi
qu'on a structuré le crébat le centre de
ressources qui s'adresse aussi sur enfin
on va dire sur la rénovation de de tout
type de patrimoine et notamment sur sur
le patrimoine aussi remarquable et
patrimoine très anciens on travaille
également sur ces sujets en lien que la
Fondation du Patrimoine pour aussi mener
ses actions aussi de meilleure
connaissance justement et de
sensibilisation à ce niveau là donc oui
tout à fait c'est tout à fait pris en
compte après précisément sur chaque
typologie je n'ai pas connaissance mais
mais c'est vraiment c'est vraiment la
démarche qui est lancée c'est assez
c'est assez récent effectivement
d'allier rénovation patrimoniale et
rénovation thermique avec en plus des
matériaux biosourcés mais en tout cas
c'est là-dessus qu'on avance
ce qu'on peut dire quand même c'est
qu'effectivement ça a commencé il y a
deux trois ans donc c'est assez récent
que nous on rencontre vraiment un
engouement de plus en plus fort quoi
plus en plus de gens qui viennent nous
voir en disant on est intéressé par ça
etc donc globalement c'est quelque chose
qui est quand même en train de se
développer
alors juste pour vous répondre nous
avons des Alecs qui travaillent sur ce
sujet depuis plusieurs années qui se
sont inscrits sur un programme européen
qui s'appelle violette et qui en fait
qui réfléchissent et qui répertorie
toutes les retours d'expérience
fructueuse qui sont en capacité d'allier
performance énergétique du bâti ancien
tout en respectant justement le bâti
ancien dans dans son entièreté dans ce
qu'il représente donc ça existe il y a
des voilà des des guides qui ont été
fournis je crois que c'est l'alecte
Bordeaux métropole sur laquelle je suis
rattaché qui a fait ça et pendant deux
fois ils ont renouvelé ce programme
européen et du coup ça permet de
travailler nous qui sommes plus sur la
performance énergétique de travailler
très étroitement avec les CAE sur lequel
justement on a pu intégrer toutes les
contraintes architecturales de bâtiments
anciens
[Musique]
la nouvelle formulation du DPE
enfin voilà avoir votre avis sur comment
comment vous l'appréhendez c'est vrai
que j'ai un questionnement sur le on a
un dispositif qui mine de rien est assez
à la fois précis complexe à mettre en
oeuvre enfin qui cherche à être quand
même très avec des avec des critères
assez précis sauf qu'on voit qu'en fait
c'est en application c'est pas si simple
et que du coup
on a des résultats qui sont pas
forcément stables ou voilà et sauf qu'on
appuie toute la politique publique sur
sur
ce DPE et ce qui m'interrogeait c'est
que pareil à travers d'autres Alecs que
j'ai pu voir fonctionner elle est plutôt
justement sur de la simplification
plutôt sur des bouquets de travaux en
fait
essayer de simplifier l'exemple de
murmures sur sur la métropole de
Grenoble mais
du coup de dire mais en gros voilà
j'isole l'enveloppe change mes
menuiseries tac c'est un bouquet de
travaux ou
au bout du compte je change la chaudière
enfin en tout cas avec des choses assez
simples et je me demandais si du coup il
y aurait pas nécessité de travailler sur
quelque chose de beaucoup plus simple en
terme de dispositif ça peut rester type
DPE mais qui permet d'avoir quelque
chose de en fait de beaucoup plus simple
avec beaucoup moins de catégories et
qui permettrait à la fois d'avoir un peu
plus de lisibilité et qui serait
peut-être aussi un peu plus motivant
pour pour passer d'une catégorie à
l'autre quoi
oui alors pour les questions
pour les dépôts nous on peut vous faire
que le retour de ce qu'on constate sur
le terrain bien sûr voilà donc pour les
DPE bon première chose ça le mérite
d'exister et donc de projeter
l'évolution et la gradation des efforts
que l'on doit faire ça c'est bien je
sais que pour le calcul c'est un petit
peu aléatoire et si vous voulez on a par
retour d'expérience on a par exemple vu
des
bâtiments des logements notamment qui
passaient d'une classe D à une classe C
simplement parce qu'ils ont changé les
fenêtres
et c'est toujours une passoire donc
voilà c'est peut-être qu'il y a revoir
qu'est-ce qu'on met derrière ces
classements et comment on fait pour
passer d'une classe à l'autre enfin
voilà et peut-être comme vous disiez
aussi de simplifier d'avoir des classes
peut-être plus éloignées qui disent
carrément si on rentre vraiment dans de
l'isolation et qu'en plus on change ses
fenêtres là qu'on passe vraiment pas
loin du BBC là d'accord mais voilà donc
c'est juste pour vous donner un exemple
de changement de classe l'inverse aussi
des logements qui étaient en C et qui
après des PE et compris après travaux
importants se retrouvent en eux
je pense que il semblerait qu'il y a
besoin de que les diagnostiqueurs et ils
se prennent cet outil
on voit des fois des choses ça fait
bizarre quoi vous expliquer ce matin qui
avait un pharmacien qui s'était
improvisé il y a de stickers dans les
Hautes-Alpes ouais pharmacien
parce qu'en fait le DPE il faut il faut
rentrer des informations techniques
dedans sinon justement c'est aléatoire
et le problème c'est que souvent les
diagnostiqueurs en bas je sais pas et
donc je coche le mur je sais pas et donc
bah ça prend quelque chose de très
générique statistique en fonction de
l'année de construction enfin du coup
c'est pas voilà c'est c'est pas précis
quoi donc ce qu'il faut c'est c'est
vraiment enfin qu'il soit utilisé de
manière scientifique va bien utiliser
quoi pour qu'il soit pour que le
résultat soit pertinent
je crois que là encore on retourne sur
un vrai problème de formation des
acteurs quoi c'est c'est
choix qu'on a tous connu effectivement
des exemples comme ça
[Musique]
et et ça ça passera par une
professionnalisation une formation plus
de contrôle plus de contrôle bien sûr
bien sûr c'est
et je pense pas qu'on remettant en cause
à chaque fois le
mécanique effectivement du DPE je veux
dire bon là on a on a fait une
modification il faut la laisser vivre
voilà mais honnêtement si on appliquait
déjà très correctement ce qui est
aujourd'hui dans les textes ça serait un
grand progrès quand même
oui le souci a pas la préoccupation
c'est que comme on pense le gouvernement
des garanties qui seraient fiabilisées
on l'a rendu opposable et qu'aujourd'hui
quand même dans les circonstances encore
dans lesquelles on se trouve
il peut y avoir un certain nombre de
contentieux qui vont s'ouvrir si c'est
déjà pas le cas c'est déjà le cas pardon
il y a pas forcément besoin d'avoir un
DPE pour savoir quel travaux faire dans
une
cas où c'est assez simple
et bien écoutez merci beaucoup pour ces
échanges on vous souhaite une bonne fin
de journée si par rapport au
questionnaire quand vous avez parvenir
vous avez des compléments que vous jugez
utile de nous faire remonter n'hésitez
pas et merci pour tout ce que vous
faites merci